summer's almost here which means
blockbuster season is kicking into gear
the month of May saw new trailers for
upcoming superhero films hard-rocking
biopics heart-pounding horror flicks and
everything in between in fact we're
already getting trailers for movies
coming out as far away as November so
hold on tight this is going to be a wild
ride here are all the trailers released
in May 2018 that are sure to blow you
away
upgrade each new trailer for upgrade
raises the stakes making this look like
one of the most unique surprises of 2018
Logan Marshall Green stars as great race
a technophobe in the near future
who's implanted with a computer chip
that turns him into a supercharged
fighting machine early critic screenings
have come out largely positive with the
general consensus being that upgrade is
a fun action-packed and supremely
violent movie perfect for kicking off
the summer blockbuster season with Leigh
Whannell creator of horror franchises
saw an insidious pulling writing and
directing duties on upgrade you can
count on a double dose of insanity look
for it in theaters on June 1st Sicario
day of the Soldado Josh Brolin and
Benicio del Toro are back in the latest
trailer for Sicario day of the Soldado
reprising their roles from 2015's
surprise gangland hit this time they're
working to create a cartel war in Mexico
using every means at their disposal to
escalate the violence and murders
judging by the trailer it's bound to be
everything that made the first one great
and then some Sicario day of the Soldado
is set to premiere in theaters on June
29th escape plan - there won't be a
theatrical release for escape plan - but
that doesn't mean it's skimping on the
action or the star power Sylvester
Stallone returns as ray Breslin who was
wrongly imprisoned in the first escape
plan this time he's putting himself
behind bars on purpose so that he can
break out a prisoner holding on to some
sensitive information it's a race
against time to find the valuable
prisoner before assassins can take him
out and then it's a race against even
less time to get out of the prison alive
Dave Bautista joins the crew and
and is returning as well you can check
it out when Escape Plan two hits blu-ray
and on-demand on June 29th ant-man and
the wasp more than perhaps any other
Marvel property ant-man thrives on its
fantastic visuals and the latest trailer
for ant-man and the wasp promises so
much size swapping it'll make your head
spin most exciting though is the
introduction that the film's villain
ghost originally introduced in the comic
pages as an enemy of Iron Man ghost is
an anti-corporate anarchist who uses a
high-tech suit to pass through solid
matter that extra element is bound to
lead to some insane fight sequences look
for ant-man and the wasp in theaters on
July 6 bleeding steel Jackie Chan is
back in action with this summer's
bleeding steel a sci-fi Wonderland
populated by fancy headgear colorful
lights and skintight leather okay so the
trailer leaves a lot to be desired but
it showcases some interesting concepts
and of course Jackie Chan kickin people
so many people bleeding Steel is going
straight to video on demand and there
are probably worse ways to spend an
evening at home look for it on July 6th
skyscraper in case you still weren't
sure what skyscraper is about the latest
trailer lays it out pretty clearly
former FBI agent will Sawyer lost his
leg in an explosion and now he examines
buildings for a living to see if they
have any security flaws while he's in
China consulting for the world's new
tallest building terrorists attacked the
building and frame him for the job since
his family's inside he has to escape the
police and get inside
[Music]
don't worry he makes it and takes out
the terrorists one by one sounds like
fun
Dwayne Johnson and director rawson
marshall thurber previously collaborated
on Central Intelligence and this newest
team-up hits theaters on July 13th the
death of Superman
say what you want about the DC EU but DC
runs the game on animated films and the
death of Superman looks like a great new
addition to the animated line this
adaptation of the iconic 1990s crossover
event sees Superman facing off against
the bloodthirsty monster doomsday and a
fight that just may see the end of the
Kryptonian superhero and at fear
thinking haven't I seen this cartoon
before you're absolutely right DC's 2007
animated film Superman doomsday was a
lackluster attempt to combine all three
parts of the comic arc into one film the
upcoming death of Superman is slated to
be the first in a two-parter allowing
more of the story to unfold on screen
look for it on July 24 Mission
Impossible fallout despite multiple
sequels the mission impossible franchise
has never failed to disappoint well
after the second one at least
in the latest trailer for Mission
Impossible fallout we learned that once
again the government doesn't trust
Ethan Hunt to get an important job done
forced to go rogue Hunt and his loyal
team have to track down a nuclear weapon
while staying two steps ahead of the CIA
and their super spy August Walker played
by Henry Cavill the stakes are just as
high as ever the stunts are just as real
and the mission is just as impossible
check out mission impossible fallout
when it lands in theaters on July 27
mile 22 starring Mark Wahlberg mile 22
follows a Special Forces operative who's
tasked with protecting a police officer
who knows the location of nine pounds of
missing radioactive bomb material the
trailer builds up the initial premise
without giving too many details away
instead focusing on Mark Wahlberg's gun
slinging skills and eco Oasis insane
martial arts the high-stakes action
thrill ride is set to hit theaters on
August 3rd the happy time murders
if the Muppets were at a gangland drama
written by Sacha Baron Cohen and
directed by Seth Rogen it might look a
lot like the happy time murders Karachi
profanity-laden comedy about a world
where puppets and humans live together
when someone starts murdering a bunch of
famous puppets - detectives embark on a
journey through the seedy underbelly of
puppet ville to solve the case what's
actually surprising about this is that
it's directed and co-produced by Jim
Henson's son Brian Henson who previously
directed such Family Fare as the Muppet
Christmas Carol and Muppet Treasure
Island the happy time murders hits
theaters on August 17th down a dark hall
uma Thurman is front and center in the
new trailer for down the dark Hall as a
headmaster of a creepy boarding school
for girls where something sinister may
be lurking in the hallways at night
based on the novel by Lois Duncan down a
dark Hall follows troubled young KITT
Gordy who's transferred to Blackwood
boarding school and finds herself face
to face with a supernatural threat the
trailer is heavy on the atmosphere
including a faceless cloaked man creepy
occult
Jules and the implication that there are
definitely sinister happenings going
down take a look on August 17 copy on
the story of a man who's wrongly
convicted of murder and sentenced to
life in a brutal prison in French Guiana
poppy Yan focuses on his harrowing
escape from prison and his adventures in
the tropics after he gets out starring
Charlie Hunnam is Papillon and rami
malek as his fellow escapee poppy Yan
looks like it hits all the right beats
for a remake it has adventure high
stakes prison escaping and a love story
holding it all together
but beyond sails into theaters on August
24th city of lies there's a lot to take
in from the first trailer for city of
lies 20 years after the murders of Tupac
Shakur and Biggie Smalls a journalist
tracks down the detective who is in
charge of the case Russell Poole played
by Johnny Depp as he digs deeper he
uncovers a twisted conspiracy involving
the LAPD and the local gangs and he's
quick to learn that when you open a scar
that's been closed for 20 years
blood is bound to flow JEP is in top
form is the jaded detective but it's
Forest Whitaker who really shines in the
trailer as journalist Jack Jackson check
out city of lies when it hits theaters
on September 7 the predator Shane
Black's predator film finally released
its first teaser dropping the
extra-terrestrial hunter right in the
suburbs of Middle America
the teaser doesn't give away many plot
details leaving the big surprises for
the film itself or maybe just future
trailers the preview begins with the
young boy playing with some kind of
alien transmitter device apparently
calling the predator to earth then we're
introduced to Boyd Holbrook scare achter
a soldier who saw the alien when its
ship crashed
the predator was written by Shane black
and Fred Dekker who previously teamed up
for 1987's the monster squad look for
the predator to hit theatres on
September 14th mowgli sure we just saw a
high-profile live action version of the
jungle book in 2016 but it never went in
a direction quite like this don't expect
any Diddy's about the bare necessities
in mowgli
promises a darker take on the young boys
jungle upbringing motion-capture legend
andy serkis directs the film and voices
Baloo
Christian Bale Benedict Cumberbatch and
Cate Blanchett also lend their voices to
the film Mowgli arrives in theaters on
October 19th Bohemian Rhapsody mr. robot
finally finds somebody to love in the
first trailer for Bohemian Rhapsody a
biopic about the iconic rock band Queen
rami malek is transformed as frontman
freddy mercury in the trailer sporting
the rockers legendary mustache and all
his onstage swagger Bohemian Rhapsody
traces the band's formation their rise
to fame and one of Mercury's final
performances at the 1985 Live Aid
concert Mike Myers is also slated to
appear in the film along with Game of
Thrones Aiden Gillen production on the
biopic has been notoriously troubled
with original director Bryan Singer
giving the boot in December 2017 after
reports of him clashing with rami malek
Dexter Fletcher was brought in to finish
the film and oversee post-production
hopefully the on-screen drama doesn't
suffer due to the behind-the-scenes
drama you can find out when Bohemian
Rhapsody premieres on November second
Robin Hood it'd be easy to call the
upcoming Robin Hood film a knockoff of
the nonstop insanity style of movies
like Kingsman but hey if you get an
action movie where you can actually see
the action everybody wins
filled with slo-mo arrow fights and
exploding horse-drawn carts Robin Hood
definitely looks like a cheese alley
overblown take on the story but there's
no denying that it's a feast for the
eyes
starring Taran Edgerton Jamie Foxx and
Ben Mendelsohn Robin Hood will follow
the familiar tale disgusted with the
corrupt government super Archer Robin
makes it his mission to steal from the
rich and give to the poor look for it in
theaters on November 21st
the sisters brothers it's a fact the
world needs more good westerns and it
looks like the sisters brothers is set
to deliver for starters it has an
amazing cast john c reilly and joaquin
phoenix star with jake gyllenhaal rizz
Ahmed and Rutger Hauer co-starring the
story follows the infamous hitmen the
sisters brothers who are hired to track
down a gold prospector who stole from a
local crime boss kicking off a darkly
comic adventure in the Old West
the trailer promises a hilarious journey
anchored by the chemistry between
Phoenix and Riley who played the skilled
yet dysfunctional brothers with so much
talent on board the sisters brothers is
definitely a movie to keep an eye on you
can find it in theaters sometime in fall
2018 thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]